one of the things i learned about you
you had never tried stand-up comedy
until you were 42 years old when you got
on the chappelle show yeah yeah yeah
that's got to be nuts because you know
when you first go out you kind of suck
yeah you're not but you're not what you
are my whole thing was it was it was the
objective was not to uh to to to to
be good it was the objective was just to
do it to break the glass to go do it and
uh see what it felt like so you didn't
set your sights high you just said no i
didn't manage a matter of fact but i
wasn't even trying to make people laugh
it was like just go up there and see if
you can
be in front of an audience and uh
and that totally choke and piss your
pants and express yourself and then get
off the stage before anybody fires
around
so when you first got up on the stage
how long how long how how long was your
set so to speak okay was it the last
factor i was supposed to do seven
minutes but i got up there and you know
i started having fun i stayed up for 15
minutes 15 minutes yeah and first time
did you prepare for it or you just
wanted no the only the only preparation
was
uh
i'm not going to let anyone uh
embarrass me that that was in my brain
i'm not i'll do anything to stop another
person tonight from embarrassing me what
do you mean if somebody heckles
oh yeah i would you would have beat the
[ __ ] out of him yeah
but that's not cool that's not cool and
you know what comedian's gotta when i
first started doing comedy that became
my my way of handling the heckler
you beat him up no i would tell him like
this is what's getting me to happen if
you say one more word now look at my
eyes and understand it i'm not
i don't have nothing to lose man i'm
gonna come over there and it's gonna be
real bad you know what's funny about
that real robert de niro there's a guy i
know his name is ron zimmerman he ended
up becoming a comedy writer and a film
writer and all this stuff he brought for
tv shows but he started out as a
stand-up comic and when i first saw him
play garvin's in uh washington d.c
he got into a fist fight with the
audience
right it was so great
yeah
i i i had to have him i had him on my
show i've never even had a comedian on
before
i said this is the greatest stand-up and
i found that he left the business
because he said he'd have to drink to do
his show and everything because it was
so freaking crazy he was interacting
with the audience and fighting with them
yeah and that that doesn't last long you
know the moment you uh
the moment you beat somebody up first of
all the club only has you there to fill
this club up so people buy
alcohol and food that's what the club is
making their money off that's right so
if
you fill the room up and then you empty
the room out
it ain't good for business you didn't
make any money and say yo you know what
uh i don't think we want you here no
more so
fighting is not really what you want to
be doing but when you're 42 years old
and the additional pressure of being
eddie murphy's brother arguably one of
the greatest stand-ups around right
that's even more pressure because
everyone's expecting you to go up there
and be a polish comedian exactly you
know especially coming up the chappelle
show and they go the rick james sketch
was so funny now this guy doesn't stand
up it must be on the same level right of
course all those expectations were there
and uh
when i look back on it and i look back
on what the material i was using back
then and all that i go you really have
to believe in god
it was a miracle